- A candle in the bathroom for your guests
so they can poop without
like, feeling self-conscious.
That's a great thing.
- Today we're going to do a
blindfolded candle challenge.
- We are gonna try and tell the difference
between cheap and expensive candles.
- I'm a candle lover.
I don't love how expensive they are, but.
- Oh, yeah.
- I (bleep) love candles.
Literally burning money.
- The most I've ever
spent on a candle was $40,
and that was for a gift for my mom.
- I don't wanna spend more
than 10 bucks on a candle.
- I have a candle that smells like weed.
- I can smell stuff from a mile away.
Usually it's pizza.
- I think I actually have a very,
very strong sense of smell.
- I have the sense of smell of a wolf.
- I don't think my nose even works.
- Ugh.
- Can't see a thing.
- Let's do it.
- Ooh, this one's curved.
We know it's fancy.
- Kind of exaggerated glass shape.
To me, that says grocery store candle.
- I feel like he's really cheating here.
- I think I might be
getting high off candles.
Is that possible?
- I know, right?
- This smells really nice.
- Yeah, I like that one.
- I would put this in my bathroom.
- Right?
- It would cover up all that nasty.
- This has to be bubblegum.
I'm envisioning like this
bright bubblegum pink
in front of me right now.
- Cheap, expensive.
- This can be cheap, too.
- I also feel like this
one's expensive, too.
- Smells like I need to have my pinky up.
- I think this is expensive.
- I think this one's fancier.
It smells like watermelon, bubblegum,
but I feel like it's stronger.
- I'm gonna stick by my answer
and say both of these
were the expensive ones.
They both just smell really good.
- Oh my god, you were right.
- Oh, hell yeah I was right.
I told you, this (bleep) smells like
I'm about to take a walk in
the (bleep) park or something.
- This says bougie on it.
- Yes, I liked this one.
It's the expensive one.
- Can we keep these candles?
- Yeah, I know, I want it.
- That is some fancy (bleep), like French?
- Oh, I smell something, it smells good.
- You do got a good nose.
I couldn't smell anything.
- I think this is the cheaper
one, but I like this one.
- I feel like the one you have right now
is the cheap candle.
- This would be a Beyonce candle.
This is what's lighting in
Beyonce's room right now.
- I think that's, this the expensive one.
- I would burn this thing
all day, all day long, baby.
- I don't (bleep) know anymore.
- This just smells fancy.
- I think this is the cheap one,
and I think this is the expensive one.
- Oh my god.
- Vanilla? No way.
How is this vanilla?
- There's no way.
- But the thing is, I
like this smell better.
- This is like summer breeze
or one of those made up names.
- This is some strong (bleep).
- I like this one better,
and I think this one
might be the expensive one.
- Definitely the cheap
one, don't you think?
The one I have?
- Yeah, I agree.
I'm getting hints of lemongrass over here.
- Wait, what if both of them are cheap?
- Oh my god, I'll be upset.
They probably are.
- They probably are.
I feel like this one might be.
- This is like a toilet in the woods.
- I think both of them are cheap.
- Wow, we're good, yes.
- Yeah, we know all about candles.
- Yeah, nailed it.
- What happened to your wolf
like smelling senses, huh?
- I could go for both.
I like both of them.
- I'm gonna go for like $20
just based on this sticker on the front.
- I think this is like, like,
close to $100, isn't it?
Like, at least 80.
- No, they're like 40 bucks.
- Huh?
- Jesus, what the hell?
- What, 64?
- No way.
- I actually think I did prefer
the smell of like, the cheaper candles.
- It doesn't have to
be cheap or expensive.
If it smells good, I think it's perfect.
- And then you feel bad about
burning your expensive candle.
- We burn them anyway.
They're not gonna last forever.
- And I'm gonna burn through
them in like, 20 hours.
- Yeah.
- There are other things you
could be burning for $60.
- Yeah, I feel like when
I come to your house party
I'm gonna judge you instantly.
- By your bathroom candles.
- The scent of your candles.
- Yeah, exactly.
You know, Oprah's house, Oprah's bathroom.
- I bet Oprah has, you
know those giant candles
that are like, three feet?
- Oh yeah, bigger than the toilet.
That's what I want.
'Cause that's when you
know you've made it.